Game of Thrones Season 8 episode 2 is
called a night of the Seven Kingdoms
it's the calm before the storm at
Winterfell with characters celebrating
life before the dead arrive Jaime
Lannister wants to help fight the White
Walkers
but Daenerys and Sansa don't trust him
because he's the brother of their enemy
Cersei
Sansa's mad because Jaime fought against
her family and Daenerys is mad because
Jaime killed her father the Mad King 20
years ago Jaime killed the king to save
a city from wildfire but when Ned Stark
found him by the throne he judged Jaime
guilty and ever after Jaime was hated as
a Kingslayer and earthbreaker
and now Jaime's judged again by Ned
Stark's daughter and the mad Kings
daughter his past is coming back to
haunt him but this time there's someone
who believes in Jaime Brienne says that
Jaime is an honorable man that he
protected her and kept his oaths Brienne
shows Jaime trust and respect like no
one else ever has
so Jaime gets his sword back widow's
wail one of the two Valyrian swords that
were melted down from Ned Stark's sword
the other sword Oathkeeper is used by
Brienne
so in Jaime and Brienne Ned's sword is
symbolically reforged his steel is
protecting how stark once more in the
hand of the man who hate once judged
guilty Jaime reveals that Cersei lied
she's not going to help the good guys
she just wants to hold the throne which
means Tyrion was wrong again his whole
plan of the White hunt and the peace
summit was with Circe's cooperation
turns out that was all for nothing
Tyrion has failed Daenerys over and over
so she threatens to replace him as hand
if Tyrion can't find purpose and self
worth serving Daenerys what will he do
Jaime apologizes to bran the boy he
crippled in Episode one Bryan didn't
tell anyone that Jaime pushed him
because if he did the Starks wouldn't
have let Jaime join them bran takes the
philosophical view that if Jaime hadn't
crippled him bran wouldn't have become
the magic three-eyed Raven and Jaime
wouldn't have become a heroic man but
bran also makes an
comment that there might not be an
afterwards for Jamie you gave a sense
that bran knows the future and he has
had some visions of the future before
but we don't know the full extent of his
powers since he became the Raven he says
he can see everything that's ever
happened to everyone and everything
that's happening right now but
apparently the visions are confused and
fragmented so in practice he'll probably
just know whatever's convenient to the
plot at the time Gendry works as a
blacksmith and aya enjoys the view just
like she did in season two
Gentry remembers iron as this plucky
young girl but I assure him that she's
something else now and closer to John
wick than to Arry the orphan boy she
talks about death and throws daggers and
Gondry's impressed confused and aroused
later Gendry brings the weapon I ordered
a sort of staff with dragonglass at both
ends it's just like the weapon of Simeon
star ice a legendary Knight mentioned in
the books he had a double-ended staff
and he was blind just like aya who was
blind but there are also hints that
Simeon was some sort of white Walker he
went to the Nightfort and had star
sapphires in his eyes like a Walker's
eyes in the last scene aya asks kendry
how many whites his fought now she asks
how many girls he's had sex with last
scene was about death this scenes about
life aya doesn't want to die a virgin so
she and Gendry have sex aya has suffered
so much death and darkness now she
finally gets some love and light but
afterwards I looks alone while Podrick
sings of sorrow and pain aya had once
asked Gendry to be her family but after
everything she's been through
I can't quiet reconnect in the books she
says that there's a hole inside her
where her heart had been that it will
never feel any better a lot of people
were shocked to see Aria have sex but no
one seems to mind when she committed
mass murder because our culture and
morals are completely [ __ ] Jaime and
Brienne make awkward small talk about
the left flank and the rise on the
ground until Brienne snaps and basically
asks what
is their relationship now they used to
hate each other then they saved each
other and now they're starting to love
each other and Brienne doesn't know how
to handle that remember when Brienne was
young some boys pretended to like her
but it turned out to be a cruel joke
they mocked her as Brienne the beauty so
it makes sense the Brienne is suspicious
when a man shows her affection and
respect especially when Jaime was always
so horrible to her
so Jaime does something that he's never
done before he humbly and sincerely
submits himself to Brienne says he's not
a great fighter anymore but that he'd be
honored to serve her Jaime rejects the
pride and cruelty that once defined him
and he honors the woman who showed him
how to be a better man also we learned
that Podrick is a badass now remember
what at guber he was in season two this
is the best character transformation
since bland sir Lannister Jorah tells
Daenerys that she should forgive Tyrians
mistakes Jorah had wanted to be Daenerys
his hand himself but he says that Tyrion
is the right man for the job
Jorah used to be so jealous and
controlling with Daenerys he undermined
her other advisors because he wanted her
all to himself now he's grown past that
and does whatever is truly best for
Daenerys he even accepts the Daenerys
loves John not him Jorah has become a
better man his arc seems complete which
probably means he'll die next episode
Jorah also advises Daenerys to make
peace with Sansa
so Daenerys find some common ground with
Sansa they're both political women with
complicated families but Sansa is
suspicious that Dany is manipulating
John exploiting his love for her
political gain
Sansa knows that her brother Rob's love
for Telesur led to his downfall
but Daenerys argues that if anything Jon
has manipulated her Daenerys came to
Westeros to take the Iron Throne but
John convinced her to come north and
fight White Walkers instead Daenerys
delayed her life's ambition partly out
of love for John but Sansa asks what
happens after the Walkers are defeated
because Daenerys still wants to rule
all of Westeros including the north
Sansa's family fought and died to rule
the north themselves Robb battled the
Lannisters Sansa and John battled the
Bolton's and Sansa doesn't want that to
be for nothing she wants an independent
North and Daenerys doesn't want to give
it to her though she really probably
should she promised the gradual is an
independent Iron Islands why not an
independent north this conflict does
feel kind of contrived but the point is
that Dany and Sansa do understand each
other better now but there's still
tension in the relationship
Theon Greyjoy arrives and says he'll
fight for the Starks he wants to redeem
himself for betraying the Starks in
season two he and Sansa have an
emotional hug they survived Ramsay
together and no one else really
understands what they went through Sansa
and Theon grew up like siblings at
Winterfell and now they're finally back
home together
Davos feeds the common folk you got to
feel sorry for these random peasants
who've been conscripted to fight in
World War Z most of the real soldiers
died in Rob's war or the Battle of the
bastards
these hapless leftovers will be
slaughtered by the walkers Gilly is also
helping the Commons she started out so
meek and afraid now she's a confident
and compassionate leader she and davos
meet a girl called teyla who looks like
Shireen the girl who taught Davos and
Gilly how to read teyla has a burn on
her face which looks like shereen's
greyscale it's also a reminder that
Shireen was burned these are the sorts
of people who will die by the thousands
when the walkers come it's always the
innocents who suffer most Gilly tells
teyla to stay in the crypt during the
battle because the Crypt is safe five
times this episode we're told that the
Crypt is safe which practically
guarantees that something awful will
happen there the Crypt is full of dead
Starks and the White Walkers can raise
the dead so maybe recently dead Starks
like Rickon will attack there are lots
of hints in the books of dead Starks
rising but most of the dead in the
crypts are very old
there wouldn't be bodies left we have
seen some
looky skeleton whites in the past but
most of the dead Starks are dust so
maybe there's some other I see danger
down there the books mentioned deeper
darker ancient levels to the Crypt which
might hold some terrible secret like a
captive Knights Queen or something or
maybe there's a secret entrance so the
walkers could attack from within or
maybe those protective magic and the
crypts really are safe
tormund barrack and air to come to
Winterfell and John gets a bear hug from
tormund they've had a crazy relationship
John once climbed the wall with
tormund's wildlings then he betrayed him
and fought against him at the battle for
Castle black then they fought together
at hardhome Winterfell and beyond the
wall this wildling leader and nights
Watchmen have become allies and friends
Tommen says the dead are coming and
everyone not at Winterfell is with them
the walkers have taken last half and are
almost at Winterfell so they could also
have karhold and the dreadfort and many
little villages as well as all the
wildling land the army of the Dead will
be huge and torment says they'll arrive
tomorrow so Winterfell has new defenses
though opening sequence shows trenches
around the castle and the plan is to
light them as a barrier of fire fire
does stop White's
the zombies but it doesn't stop White
Walkers the ice creatures the walkers
are vulnerable to dragonglass
so there's dragonglass on the walls and
on caltrops and there's heaps of
dragonglass weapons and they've also got
trebuchet x' and traps but the army of
the dead is too big the whites don't
sleep or stop and every human who's
killed can be raised again as a white so
everyone gets together and works out a
plan the walkers are led by the night
king and john hopes that if the night
King dies all the walkers and whites
will die too and bran says that the
night king will come for him bran was
marked by the night king in season six
it's like a GPS tracker so he always
knows where bran is so they plan to use
bran as bait putting him in the godswood
to lure the night king Theon and the
Ironborn will guard bran which is cool
because there was foreshadowing
season one that theon would have a
battle in the godswood this seems like
the perfect setup for Theon to
heroically sacrifice himself John says
that they'll keep the Dragons nearby to
protect bran and wait for the night king
but he says they won't use the dragons
in the field which seems really dumb
dragons breathe fire they're not good at
protecting wheelchair-bound wizards in
flammable forests they're really good at
burning lots of zombies surely the
dragons are the only real hope of
stopping the dead
they should have flew out and burned the
dead before they even arrived maybe
Danny and John are worried about the
night Kings Olympic javelin skills but
that means relying on foot soldiers to
hold off an endless zombie horde long
enough to kill the night king assuming
the night king even shows up so like the
white home's last season this plan is
pretty ridiculous it's almost like this
is a TV show and it's meant to be
dramatic the interesting bit is when
bran explains the motivation of the
White Walkers
he says the night king wants to erase
this world and bring an endless night he
specifically wants to kill bran because
as the three-eyed Raven bran is the
world's memory in the books the magic of
the weirwood stores the souls of the
dead and remembers the history of the
earth sam says that memory is what makes
us human and forgetting his death
Thrones author George Martin is a
melancholy romantic he's been writing
for decades about ghosts and songs and
lost loves all different echoes of the
past and that shines through in Game of
Thrones the story is about vengeance and
grief and loyalty and guilt all feelings
that are rooted in memories of loss and
love that's why the North remembers why
the Starks treasure their crypts why Ned
Stark and Rhaegar are still important
characters even though they're long dead
memory makes us human so it makes sense
that the ultimate evil in this story is
a metaphor for forgetting our humanity
that said it's all very [ __ ] abstract
shouldn't the big bad guys have a more
specific motivation there are all these
weird hints of baby sacrifice
ouki spirals ancient mystery the books
hint at ancient pacts and secret
bloodlines there's cold hands and joram
ins horn the five thoughts and
bloodstone Emperor surely that adds up
to something more than this metaphor
there may still be secrets to reveal
about the walkers whether in this show
or the prequel show or in upcoming books
and tyrion speaks with bran it is crazy
that bran is apparently an omni see and
psychic no at all yet no one asks him
what he knows or what his powers are
Tyrion at least sees the value in
knowledge so he asks to hear brans story
but the same cuts out before we hear
anything so what did Tyrion learn on the
excellent still watching podcast the
writer of this episode Bryan cogman
suggested that Tyrion and bran just
talked about brans journey and nothing
super important happened but Tyrion does
seem more optimistic about the battle
after speaking with bran maybe bran did
tell him something that'll help in the
fight
missandei says hi to some northern girls
man they run off she's traded as an
unwelcome foreigner here and grey worm
says they should go somewhere else after
the war Musante wants to go back to naff
her homeland where she lived before she
was enslaved the nathi are called the
peaceful people they don't eat meat and
don't kill people even in self-defense
so they're often attacked by slavers or
conquerors but their enemies don't last
long because na is full of butterflies
that carry a disease that kills
outsiders of course that would mean that
kil grey worm so maybe that's only true
in the books point is this is a touching
moment of two lovers dreaming of a
happily ever after so it's the perfect
setup for some heart-wrenching tragedy
next episode maybe grey worm or
missandei who will die Sam ed and John
talk on the walls of Winterfell we
finally say John's direwolf ghost though
he's still much smaller than in the
books the book Dyle wolves get huge and
have deep symbolic and magic connections
with H stark Jon salmon aired were in
the Nights Watch together along with
gran and pip and the rest they survived
wildlings and whites and worse
but now it's just these three left Sam
and John laugh had aired for being a
virgin which is a bit rich the Nights
Watch oats are understood to mean having
no sex John and Sam broke that rule but
the rules are out the window now anyway
because the wall has fallen and the
Nights Watch all but dissolved still
John salmon Edie keep the important bits
of their oath they are the swords in the
darkness the Watchers on the walls the
shield that guards the realms of men
the Nights Watch was founded thousands
of years ago to defend the living from
the dead
and tonight everyone at Winterfell is
Knights watch Tyrion and Jaime reflect
on how far they've come last time they
were here Jaime was a proud Golden Lion
and Tyrion a drunken whoremonger
now Jaime has lost his pride and his
hand and Tyrion has lost his taste for
prostitutes misses partly tied to his
grief vishay and Tyrion also mentions
self-betterment he's more focused now on
making a difference in the world
Tyrion mentions how mad their father
would be if he knew his sons were
fighting for the Starks cuz Tywin was
brutal in his war to destroy the Starks
and make House Lannister a dynasty to
last a thousand years
but now House Lannister is all but gone
and it's the stark legacy that lives on
Game of Thrones is a dark story where
good guys die but the message isn't
totally bleak acts of heroism and love
outshine the darkness so long as they're
remembered the Lannisters are joined by
Brienne pod
tormund and Davos torment tells a
ridiculous story about suckling on a
giant he's got heaps of that stuff in
the books and he claims that a bear bit
off half his penis but that his penis is
still twice as large as anyone elses so
these unlikely companions share warmth
and wine in the face of probable death
tomorrow meanwhile the Hound sits alone
in the cold until Arya comes along in
season four I and the Hound were kindred
spirits they both use violence and hate
to hide their loneliness and fear but
after they parted ways the hounds become
all heroic fighting for the good guys
when he used to only care
self ayah asks why he changed and the
hound replies he started fighting for
aya it seems that their bond toward the
hound that it's worth fighting to
protect others
beric Dondarrion showed up he used to be
on ayahs death list for selling candy to
Melisandre but ayahs let go of that
berrak talks about his God the Lord of
Light and says this is his moment the
Lord of Light is all about good versus
evil light vs. dark all that Zoroastrian
stuff next episodes battle for the dawn
might be barracks time to fulfill his
destiny in some fiery sacrifice in the
books Barret gives up his life force to
resurrect Catelyn so maybe Barrack will
resurrect someone next episode
tormund is shocked to learn that Brienne
isn't a knight because in Westeros women
aren't allowed to be Knights part of the
point of Brienne's character is to show
how unjust this sexist system is Brienne
is more brave and selfless and honorable
than most any actual knight yet her
society denies her knighthood because of
her gender
tormund calls [ __ ] on that and Jamie
makes Brienne a knight this is the
ultimate vindication for Brienne the
acknowledgment and respect that she's
always deserved it's also important for
Jamie in many ways he was a failed night
an Oathbreaker who hurt innocent people
now he raises up a true knight this is
an intimate moment for Brienne and Jaime
the scene almost feels like a wedding
Jaime declares his faith in Brienne just
as she did for him before Jaime and
Brienne might never kiss or have sex but
this knighting is a moment of love Sam
gives Jorah the Valyrian sword heart's
pain this was the sword of Sam's father
Randall but Randall was an [ __ ] and
Sam took the sword to represent his
rejection of his father instead Sam says
that Geo Mormont was like a father to
him Gio was Commander of the Nights
Watch and was Joris father Jorah failed
his father by slaving and leaving
Westeros but now Sam gives Jorah heart's
pain to guard the realms of men
as Jia would have wanted so this is
another example of a character whose
memory long out lives his death but it's
also the story of a man who rejects his
biological father and chooses another
man which could be relevant for John
John is the biological son of Rhaegar
but Ned Stark is his father
Podrick sings a song about love and loss
and memory it's about the ghosts of the
friends and family that these characters
have lost and the ghosts of the people
who they used to be it's a moment of
bittersweet melancholy as they share one
last night of love and light in the face
of death and forgetting a dream of
spring as winter comes the song also
ties deeply into the law the song is
called Jenny's song named for Jenny of
old stones a mysterious woman who lived
fifty years ago she dwelt among ruins
danced with ghosts and more flowers in
her hair
Prince Duncan Targaryen fell in love
with her and gave up his crown to marry
her Jenny had a friend who was a witch
and she claims to be a child of the
forest this witch is still alive in the
books as the ghost of high heart and she
makes a bunch of accurate prophecies
back in the day she prophesied that the
prince that was promised the hero who'll
save the world will be born of the line
of the Mad King Aerys and his sister so
they got married and had Rhaegar Viserys
and an heiress Rhaegar was born at the
tragic fire of summerhall
which killed Prince Duncan and possibly
Jenny Rhaegar spent his mo teenage years
in the ruins of summerhall singing sad
songs some fans speculate that Rhaegar
may have written Jenny's song this may
be the song that Rhaegar played to woo
Lyanna stark leading to the birth of
their child
John so Jenny's song is a thread of
prophecy and melancholy that runs from
John and Danny back through Rhaegar and
summerhall to Jenny and now John reveals
to Daenerys that Rhaegar is his father
this means that Daenerys is John's aunt
and John has a better claim to the
throne than she does Daenerys has fought
for the throne for seven seasons so
she's deeply shaken by John's claim
of course John doesn't want the throne
which could tie back to Jenny's song
Prince Duncan gave up his crown out of
love for Jenny
so maybe John will give up his crown for
Daenerys or maybe Daenerys will give up
hers remember Sam asked her last episode
if Daenerys would give up her crown
alternatively John and Danny could just
get married and ruled together but such
a happy ending seems unlikely the White
Walkers arrived at Winterfell
Jenny song and kind of this whole
episode is about characters haunted by
the dead by the metaphorical ghosts of
the past but they're also haunted by a
very literal army of the Dead the
zombies are here and they're led by a
whole lot of White Walkers
remember whites are the zombies and
they're pretty easy to kill but the
White Walkers are the ice people who
lead the dead and have only seen a few
of them now there are dozens or hundreds
of walkers at Winterfell where did they
all come from
we know that Craster gave his babies to
be transformed into White Walkers and he
was probably not the only person doing
this there are wildlings in the far
north rumored to worship cold gods so
over thousands of years the walkers must
have slowly built up these numbers the
walkers also have zombie giants and
animals like polar bears and there are
legends about giant ice spiders the
White Walkers are led by the night king
riding the dragon Vasari on but we don't
see him here some fans speculated that
the night King won't join this battle
and instead he'll fly south and attack
King's Landing turning its million
inhabitants into another army of the
Dead this would be similar to the Battle
of the whispering wood when Robb Stark
split his army and surprise attacked
Jaime Jaime mentions the whispering word
to this episode the excellent history of
Westeros podcast points out another
possible parallel in Thrones history in
the dance of the Dragons Aymond
Targaryen a dragon rider with a blue
sapphire I split from his army and
attacked elsewhere
so daemon Targaryen and his lover
nettles chased him down on their dragons
may be similarly Jon
Narus will have to chase down the night
king but that's just a guess we'll find
out soon this is the second episode of a
six episode season and not very much has
happened
some fans dismiss this as pointless far
knuckling but the point of these
episodes is to remind us why we care
about these characters before the next
episodes rip them away this episode is
Jenny's song remembering the ghosts that
give the characters humanity in the face
of darkness and death when Brienne is
knighted tyrion calls her a night of the
Seven Kingdoms that's the title of a
collection of Game of Thrones prequel
stories about a night called Duncan the
tall George Martin has hinted that dunk
is an ancestor of Brienne they're very
similar characters like Brienne dunk is
an underdog he's not the smartest or the
strongest and it's implied that he's not
even really a night but he's brave and
honorable and he upholds his vows here's
a quote from the audiobook he charged me
to be a good night and true to obey the
seven gods defend the weak and innocent
serve my lord faithfully and defend the
realm with all my might and I'm swore
that I would in a night of the Seven
Kingdoms dunk adventures across Westeros
with a Targaryen kid he meets a young
three-eyed Raven and young Walder Frey
and he kisses the woman who later
becomes Jaime Lannister's
great-grandmother you can read all of
donks stories for free today by signing
up for a trial with audible members get
a book each month and if you cancel you
keep the books you can read in the car
or the gym or while drinking and waiting
for the apocalypse
sign up at audible.com slash ASX thanks
for watching and thanks to the artists
for their work thanks to the patrons
including bloody tyrant Scarlett random
vowels Geena and Sam London of house
Wimbley first of his name lord of Union
Square and protector of the realm Cheers